مراكز الاقتراع امام الناخبين في تركيا
للتصويت في الانتخابات البرلمانيه
والرئاسيه
طرف الصراع بالسودان يستانفان في جده
المحادثات لتنفيذ خطط ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه
بعد سريان وقف اطلاق النار هدوء في غزه
واسرائيل تعلن اعاده فتح معبر تدريجيا
[موسيقى]
اذا قبل نحو ساعتين من الان فتحت مراكز
الاقتراع ابوابها امام الناخبين الاتراك
لاختيار رئيسهم وبرلمانهم الناخبون وكما
نشاهد في هذه الصور المباشره يدلون
باصواتهم في اكثر من 1991 الف صندوق
اقتراع من اجل انتخاب رئيس للبلاد لمده
خمس سنوات واختيار اعضاء البرلمان
[موسيقى]
اذا فتحت مراكز الاقتراع في تركيا ابوابها
امام الناخبين للادلاء باصواتهم في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه والرئاسيه
ويتنافس على كرسي الرئاسه ثلاثه مرشحين هم
مرشح تحالف الشعب الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب
اردوغان ومرشح تحالف الامه كمال
ومرشح تحالف الاجداد سنان
التحالفات السياسيه التركيه المتنافسه
[موسيقى]
الائتلاف الحاكم يضم حزب العداله والتنميه
حزب الحركه القوميه
حزب الوحده الكبرى او الاتحاد الكبير
[موسيقى]
من اسطنبول تنضم الينا مفرده العربيه
كريستيان بيسري ومن انقره العربيه فاطمه
فهد مرحبا بكما معي في هذه النشره ابدى
معك كريستيان عن نسب الاقبال حتى اللحظه
كيف يمكن الحديث عنها واي الفئات العمريه
التي توجهت الى مركز الاقتراع بجانبك منذ
صباح حتى الان
صباح الخير نايف لك ولكل المشاهدين
حقيقه نسبه الاقتراع هنا تعد يعني
وسطيه نوعا ما لا يمكن ان نتحدث عن نسب
اقبال كثيفه على غرار باقي صناديق
الاقتراح حيث
سيادلي زعيم المعارضه هو المرشح الاخر
بصوته في انقره وبالتالي يمكن ان نتحدث عن
فتور نوعا ما في الاقبال على صندوق
الاقتراع هذا في اسطنبول
ولكن قيل لنا بان الاقبال سيزداد مع تقدم
ساعات النهار نحن يعني لا نزال نتحدث عن
بدء الفتح الصناديق فقط منذ ساعتين لاحظنا
بان المقبلين على الاقتراع هم من تقريبا
الاربعين وما فوق
نسبه اقبال الشباب ضئيله جدا على صناديق
الاقتراع هنا اشير نايف بان حوالي خمسه
ملايين شاب مما يسمى الجيل زاد او الجيل
الذي خلق في فتره الثوره الانترنت
من الهم من ممن سينتخبون لاول مره
وبالتالي هم من الفئه التي يمكن القول
بانها
ربما تقلب المعادله في حال صبت في خانه
مرشح واحد فقط بعض استطلاعات الراي تتحدث
عن ان معظم هؤلاء سيعطونا صوتهم لك للجدار
اوغلو فقط من باب التغيير لانهم يعني وعوا
وكبروا فقط على وجود اردوغان في السلطه
وبالتالي من المرجح ان تذهب اصواتهم الى
زعيم المعارضه
الرجال والنساء الذين استطلعنا ارائهم هنا
باغلبيتهم يقولون بانهم سيصوتون لاردوغان
ويفسرون ذلك على انهم جيل فتره ما قبل حكم
اردوغان وما بعده وراوا يعني الازدهار
الكبير الذي حدث في عهده تحدثوا عن بنيه
التحتيه عن المستشفيات
عن وضع تركيا بالوضعها الدولي على الساحه
الدوليه والاقليميه يقولون بانهم يعني
اعطاها ثقل
عالمي اذا صح التعبير وان الازمه
الاقتصاديه هي ازمه طارئه حدثت فقط في
السنوات الاخيره وبالتالي يمكن حلها ولا
يجب اعتبارها اساس
لتقرير من سينتخبون فاطمه ذات الفتور
الموجود في
اسطنبول موجود لديك ايضا كذلك في انقره
بمعنى ان نسب
الاقبال لا تزال ضئيله حتى اللحظه ام لا
في انقره المشهد يختلف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكريستيانو من اسطنبول يعني على
العكس تماما هنا نسب الاقبال كثيفه جدا
وكبيره جدا خصوصا في هذه المنطقه
مؤيده للمعارضه ومحسوبه على المعارضه بشكل
كبير غالبيه من نتحدث اليهم
من ياتون الى هذا المركز تحديدا يصوتون
لاردوغان ساحاول اخبركم في جوله الى احد
غرف الاقتراع نايف التي سيدني بها ايضا
كليجدار اوغلو بصوته هذه الغرفه على يسار
الكاميرا تحديدا هي التي سيدلك ريشجار
اوغلو بصوته فيها اليوم في تمام الساعه 11
بحسب مصادرنا التي تحدثنا اليها يتراوح
عدد الناخبين لكل صندوق انتخابي بين 360
و380 ناخبا يعني داخل هذه المدرسه التي
تدعى مدرسه ارجنتين الابتدائيه وهي
المدرسه بالمناسبه التي تخرج منها كليش
دار اوغلو يوجد بها 18 صندوق انتخابي هناك
حركه كثيفه الكتيف من المواطنين الاتراك
للتصويت صراحه منذ الساعات الاولى
والدقائق الاولى لفتح هذا المركز وفتح
صناديق الاقتراع
الناخبين او الناخبون المسجلون في هذا
المركز يصل عددهم الى 7000 ناخب ومن ضمنهم
طبعا كمال كليجدار اوغلو الذي سياتي
للادلاء بصوته هنا في هذا المركز داخل كل
مدرسه يوجد عدد معين من الصناديق نايف كما
ذكرت يعني من 360 الى 380 صندوق
كليجدار اوغلو ياتي الى هذا الحي الذي
يسمى شوكور ام بار شكور امبار في منطقه
هي المنطقه المحسوبه على المعارضه كما
ذكرت قبل قليل تحدث قبل قليل ومن اللافت
يعني تعليقنا وتعقيبا على ما قالته
كريستيان بانهم هناك في اسطنبول والمؤيدين
لاردوغان يقولون بان لا يجب النظر الى
الاقتصاد وانه سيتحسن وما الى ذلك تحدثت
قبل قليل الى شابه عدد كبير من الشباب
والشابات يدون باصواتهم
فعندما تحدثت اليها عن سبب تاييدها لك
ليشدار قالت بان الاقتصاد هو احد الاسباب
واهم الاسباب وحقيقه انهارت باكيه بسبب
هذه النقطه تحديدا وكررت كان من اللافت
انها كررت ادارات الدعائيه التي تستخدمها
يعني المعارضه بانكم فقراء كل يوم اكثر من
اليوم السابق وكلما زاد وجود الدكان او
استمر اردوغان ستكونون افقر مما سبق وهذه
الشعارات التي رددتها لي عندما تحدثت معي
حقيقه كريستيان من المتوقع
يعني اي فئه متوقعه ان تعزف عن الاقتراع
في هذه الانتخابات
بالفعل نايف يتوقع يكون هناك عزوف ما بين
نسبه 12% الى 15% عن المشاركه في هذه
الانتخابات
وابرزهم هم من مؤيدي اردوغان السابقين
الذين هم غير راضيين عن ادائه في الاونه
الاخيره ولكن بنفس الوقت لا يريدون اعطاء
صوتهم للمرشح
باعتبار بانه لا يمثل مبادئهم ولن يحافظ
على الهويه التركيه وحتى بعضهم يذهب ابعد
من ذلك بانه بانهم لن نصوت لاردوغان ولكن
لن نصوت للكفار بنفس الوقت واشير هنا الى
ان اردوغان بالامس بخطابه عندما كان ينتقد
كالشتار اوكلوا وبرمجه قال بانه هؤلاء
الذين يدعمون الشذوذ وبالتالي هذه الفئه
من المؤيدين لاردوغان من المفترض ان تعزف
عن
المشاركه في الاقتراع ايضا هناك حديث عن
بعض الجيل الشاب الذي يعني هو غير مهتم
اصلا
بالسياسه ولا يعنيه من هذا الموضوع سوى
انه الفئه القليله منهم من ربما
سيقترعون
اشكرك جزيل الشكر منفذه العربيه كريستيانو
بيسري من اسطنبول للشكر ايضا لمنفذه
العربيه فاطمه فهد من العاصمه انقره شكرا
جزيلا لكم
[موسيقى]
استلم ضفه السلطه منذ عام 2003
اول رئيس منتخب مباشره عام 2014
شهدت فتره حكمه محاوله انقلاب فاشله عام
تمكن حزبه من الفوز باستفتاء عام 2017
وفرضي تعديلات دستوريه
تحولت تركيا في عهده من النظام البرلماني
للرئاسي
حكم عقدين ويسعى لولايه رئاسيه ثالثه قد
تم وعودا اقتصاديه عده تستهدف الشباب
والتضخم
[موسيقى]
تجددت الاشتباكات بالخرطوم بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع حيث افاد
مراسل العربيه بان الاشتباكات العنيفه
تركزت في ام درمان ووسط الخرطوم واضاف
المراسل ان الطيران الحربيه واصل التحليق
في العاصمه الخرطوم مشيرا الى ان تجدد
الاشتباكات المسلحه تلك يفاقم من المعاناه
الانسانيه للسودانيين في تلك المناطق
وينتظر ان يستانف طريق الصراع في السودان
اليوم الاحد طرفات الصراع في السودان
المحادثات بشان كيفيه تنفيذ خطط ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه وفق ما كشفت عنه
وكاله رويترز نقلا عن مسؤول الدبلوماسيه
سعودي واوضحت الوكاله ان المحادثات ستركز
على سحب القوات من المناطق المدنيه
بالاضافه الى فتح ممرات امنه واخلاء
المناطق المدنيه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل ايضا
دوي انفجارات في مقاطعه سومي باوكرانيا في
الجزء الذي تسيطر عليه كييف
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنا المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيليه عن فتحي معبري بيت
حانون وكرم ابو سالم في قطاع غزه بشكل
جزئي وتدريجي واضاف افيخاي انه سيتم ايضا
اعاده فتح المجال البحري وفقا لتقييم
الاوضاع وياتي فتح المعابر مع قطاع غزه
بعد دخول اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار بين
اسرائيل وحركه الجهاد الاسلامي بوساطه
مصريه وقالت اسرائيل ان الهدوء سوف يقابل
بالهدوء
ومع دخول اتفاق وقف اطلاق نار بين الفصائل
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل حيز التنفيذ يشهد
قطاع غزه حاله من الهدوء الحذر ووفقا
لمصادر الصحفيه مصريه فان الاتفاق يتضمن
الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار ووقف استهداف
المدنيين ووقف هدم المنازل وقال مصدر مقرب
من حركه الجهاد ان اسرائيل لم تعطي
التزاما بوقف اغتيال قيادات الحركه بينما
تعهدت مصر بالعمل على تجميد سياسه
الاغتيالات لامد طويل
ورحب البيت الابيض باعلان وقف اطلاق النار
في غزه مشيدا بالحكومه المصريه
لتوسطها في الاتفاق وقالت المتحدثه باسم
البيت الابيض كارينجان ان المسؤولين
الامريكيين عملوا عن كثب مع شركاء
الاقليميين للتوصل الى هذا الحل للاعمال
القتاليه من اجل منع سقوط المزيد من
الخسائر في الارواح واعاده الهدوء الى
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين على حد سواء
وفضفه الغربيه افادت وسائل اعلام باصابه
شاب برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه بعد اقتحام
البلده القديمه في مدينه نابلس هذا
واندلعت اشتباكات بين القوات الاسرائيليه
وفلسطينيين في مدينه نابلس في اعقاب عمليه
الاقتحام اسفر عن اعتقال شخصين
صوت مليون و800 الف موريتاني لاختياري
برلمان جديد ومجالس جهويه وبلديه في
انتخابات تشهد تنافسا حادا خصوصا في
العاصمه وكبريات المدن بين خمسه وعشرين
حزبا
اقبال الكبير على مراكز الاختراع في
الانتخابات الثلاثيه البرلمانيه والجهويه
والبلديه يؤشر الاحتمال تسجيل نسبه مشاركه
مرتفعه ورغم حده المنافسه خصوصا في
العاصمه وكبريات مدن البلاد فقط طبع
الهدوء واجواء المراكز الانتخابيه
الاقبال كثيف واعلن المكاتب مسجل فيها قدر
من الخلق وفم في سير العمليه الانتخابيه
مما يسالنا عندنا تخوف اعلن العمليه
الانتخابيه الذي قد ما يكتمل كل مكتب قد
ما يكمل عدد عدد
الناخبين نحن نقول الامور كامله الجهات
المعنيه
وتدخل وتدخل اللجنه بنفس الوقت وتدخل جهه
اي ملاحظه
اللجنه جاهزه
لجميع المشاكل
يتنافسوا في الانتخابات الجاريه 25 حزبا
على مقاعد البرلمان البالغه 176
تعتمد النسبيه لانتخاب نصفها وثلاثه عشر
مجلسا جهويا ونحو 240 بلديه
تكتسي الانتخابات الحاليه اهميه خاصه فهي
تنظم على مشارف انتخابات رئاسيه مقرره
للعام القادم يرجح ان يترشح فيها الرئيس
الحالي لعهده ثانيه وهو ما يفسر حده معركه
تعزيز المواقع بين اطراف العمليات
السياسيه ابراهيم مصطفى العربيه نواكشوط
اعلنت تسلطات الاوكرانيه سماع عدوي
انفجاراتهم في مقاطعه سومي باوكرانيا
وكرسون في الجزء الذي تسيطر عليه الكيان
جاء ذلك فيما دوت صافرات الانذار في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه وعدد من المقاطعات
تحسبا للقصف الروسي هذا واعلن محافظ
مقاطعه
انفجارات متكرره في المقاطعه بعد انباء عن
تحليق طيران فوق المنطقه الصناعيه
افتتحت مراكز الاقتراع ابوابها امام
الناخبين في الانتخابات العامه في تايلاند
ودعي نحو 52 مليون تايلاندي للتصويت بينهم
اربعه ملايين يقترعون للمره الاولى بحسب
مراسل وكاله فرانسبريس حيث تعد انتخابات
الاحد الاولى من نوعها على مستوى البلاد
منذ الاحتجاجات المؤيده للديمقراطيه عام
2020 التي دعت الى اصلاح شامل للنظام
الملكي بعد ان تضائلت حدتها تحت تاثير
جائحه كوبي تسعه عشر وقمع السلطات لها
حضر المركز الامريكي للانذاري بالاعاصير
من اعصار موكا الذي يقترب من سواحل
بنغلاديش ومينامار في خليج البنغال ما
يهدد نحو مليون لاجئ من الروهينغ واخرين
من سكان المنطقه المنخفضه اوضح المركز ان
الاعصار سترافقه رياح تبلغ سرعتها 259
كيلومترا في الساعه موضحا ان ذلك يعادل
اعصارا من الدرجه الخامسه وهي الاعلى على
سلم سفير سمسم وفي وقت سابق اصدرت الضوء
في وقت سابق اصدرت الدولتان اوامر لمئات
الالاف من السكان باخلاء منازلهم قبل هبوب
الاعصار العنيف
حلقه جديده من الجدل الذي يثيره تطبيق تيك
توك في الولايات المتحده حيث رفع مسؤول
تنفيذي كبير سابق بشركه الام للتطبيق باي
دانس دعاوى على الشركه كما ينظر بخطر وشيك
قد يهدد وجودها
حلقه جديده يشهدها مسلسل التطبيق الاكثر
جدلا في الولايات المتحده تيك توك مدير
تنفيذي سابق للشركه
يرفع دعوى قضائيه بعد عده سنوات من فشل
الوصول الى تسويه مع الشركه
الفصل غير المشروع كان الشكوى الاولى التي
قدمها
والتي اتخذتها الشركه بسبب كشف يو لمخطط
عالمي لسرقه الملكيه الفكريه لشركات اخرى
والربح منها
من بين الادعاءات الاكثر لفتا للانتباه في
دعوى السيد يو ان مكاتب بايد دانس في بكين
لديها وحده خاصه من اعضاء الحزب الشيوعي
الصيني يشار اليها بسم اللجنه مهمتها
مراقبه التطبيقات الشركه وارشاد الشركه
لتطبيق القيم الشيوعيه الاساسيه وامتلاك
مفتاح الموت الذي قد يؤدي الى ايقاف تشغيل
التطبيقات الصينيه
ولعل اكثر ما اكد شكوك الامريكيه حول
التطبيق ادعاء السيد يوم ابقاء اللجنه ضمن
دائره الوصول الفائق الى جميع بيانات
الشركه حتى البيانات المخزنه في الولايات
المتحده
تظهر ادعاءات السيد يو كذلك ان مهندسي
شركه نسخوا مقاطع فيديو ومنشورات من
تطبيقات كسناب شات وانستجرام ثم نشروها
دون اذن والهدف كما يدعي السيد ديو خلقه
جيش من الروبوتات لتعزيز ارقام المشاركه
ورفع قيمتها السوقيه باسرع وقت ممكن
خلال الاشهر التي عمل فيها سيد يوب من عام
2017 الى 2018 شهد على تعديل الخوارزميات
لرفع محتوى يعبر عن كراهيه اليابان بجعل
المنشورات اكثر بروزا للمستخدمين يبدو ان
الفوضى داخل الشركه بدات تتسرب فبعد ان
طالت المؤسس تهم برشوه مسؤول كبير مكلف
بتنظيم الانترنت في الصين في 2018
ها هي الشركه تتلقى ضربه موجعه وتتهم
بالخروج عن القانون في دوله يستخدم
تطبيقها اكثر من 150 مليون امريكي كرم
حناوي العربيه
في نهايه النشره تذكيرا بابرز عناوينها
فتحوا مراكز الاقتراع امام الناخبين في
تركيا للتصويت في الانتخابات البرلمانيه
والرئاسيه
الصراع في السودان يستانفان في جده
المحادثات لتنفيذ خطه ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه
بعد سريان وقف اطلاق النار هدوء في غزه
واسرائيل تعلن اعاده فتح معبر تدريجيا
ساعه اخباريه نلقاكم فيها بعد قليل الى
اللقاء
فقرير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات